hi guys so we just did something really
really really huge what did we do
we bought a patch a dirt okay so we
finally did the very first big steps
towards our home so if you guys know
that we are now in the home line process
and we were talking about how we fell in
love with this one place that we were
calling plan a and this house is not a
home yet because it's just a patch of
dirt so we did the very first step
towards purchasing this home which is to
put the deposit so we just finished like
signing their entire lives away there's
a whole folder here we just or signing
papers forever
it looked like more than an hour to go
for everything with our agent Kevin so
it's really exciting because we get to
see our home being built from the ground
up so it's really excited we've already
been coming here pretty much every
single week and checking out the
progress of that patch of dirt because
they're putting in like piping and
and I don't know foundation stuff
they're doing that stuff so we've been
taking photos like and Christina came by
a couple weeks ago and then we brought
Bart in jail last week and so now it's a
like it's the most official we could get
at this point that that piece of dirt is
ours because we gave the deposit but
it's not gonna be a thousand percent
ours until we get the down payment and
then that's when we sign the papers and
then it goes into escrow and all this
grown-up stuff and I was really
confusing and boring but still the point
is we are getting us I'm really excited
I was like how do you feel I feel happy
yeah I know I dude you get to move
spools Oh in the middle of the year
because our helmets not gonna be fully
built out until about January ish so we
have to wait all this time but yeah
we're gonna have to be very very patient
and wait for our house to be built but
in the meantime you get to say goodbye
to your friends or your current school
yeah that's true yeah are you gonna be
sad you're gonna miss some yeah
you get to live in music and how sick is
it for you guys to see the house being
built I know what is pretty cool I am so
jealous of you because you got to grow
up and nothing about brand-new homes
like you're always look first ready I've
done this process before like the house
that my technique my teenage years in
fifth grade I kept we kept going to the
lot where we were building the house I
got a home built from the ground up
and then we went the day that they
poured this dimension in the driveway
were you visited the house and we I
wrote my name - oh it's so cute I'm so
jealous because that's something I've
always wanted my entire me was first of
all to live in a house and I know it
sounds sad but I lived in a trailer park
most of my childhood I didn't get to
live in an actual single-family home and
it was like trailer park in apartments
and I didn't get to live in a house
until I was 14 or 15 and then I have to
live in Mexico and then just this whole
thing right so I've always just wanted
to live in a house because currently
we're living in a condo or townhome
thing
exactly oops we're getting chick-fil-a
but um yes but yeah so I am just so
excited to just even have a house and
call it my own and the fact that it's
brand-new because I've always always
always lived in really old places like
the homes that I have gotten to live in
they've been really horrible and smelly
like they smell like the 70s
my that house I was talking about when I
was 14 it was built in like 30s so it
was a really old house and I don't know
I'm just super excited to finally get
that like childhood dream come true I'm
living in a brand-new home so I'm really
excited so anyway we're heading to meet
with Barton geo and David because we're
all gonna be camping at this lake it's
gonna be Isaac's first time ever can be
with us yeah that is true never tempt
with us before I never tempt every time
we go camping Isaac's always at his dad
and this time he was supposed to be at
his dad's this weekend we're like no he
has to come with us we got to go camping
so you excited yeah that's why he has
this pillow - you're ready with your
pillow relax
right now exactly because it's about an
hour away where we have to go but I'm
already with my bar mail when we do barb
a barbell yeah that's a little barbell
hat I have a barbell off hoody
I'm gonna pull out later if it gets cold
some pulley barbell down repin repin
barbell train their barbell Brigade okay
alphas really hot here not sponsored by
a chick-fil-a we shut you out so much
[Music]
we're Vietnam we're camping
first things first get the sprays on
because I imagine our tent would be like
go right over there somewhere and while
we're building it it'll just be Sun
beating down on us very friendly it's
[Applause]
cold
do you like camping yeah
oh we can't three times oh no camping of
course yeah yeah campaign la is really
dry
the camping I did in Texas we used to go
to East Texas near Tyler Tyler Texas
it's a town and the campgrounds there's
like really tall like trees and stuff
and it's always like really shady like
wet and cold sometimes if you go in the
fall that's my favorite time to go
camping like when it's cold we should go
whenever it's Christmas
[Music]
five into your hand you're caught
red-handed mister what are you looking
for trying to steal my keys try steal my
car Grand Theft Auto notice the other
day I was walking around he could see
the outline of the pot like whatever is
in your pocket the shape of it and he
knows where my phone is crazy
what are you doing have you ever heard
of personal space take
what do you got going on there Isaac
we're gonna make my own little team I
know so we got we got parents going and
we got the kid tank going you're gonna
pitch his first ten I'd really easy
thank you so don't worry about it I
don't know how to do it okay so first
[Music]
[Applause]
force it put some muscle in there over
here set this ablaze that little teeny
foul yup so we're gonna make sure this
is nice so satisfying drink primal yes
it is hyper from what's for dinner
tonight we've got some beef stew action
how to pick things that are easy to cook
walking happy you know it's pretty like
we're made this is like this is like
high-class camping
that's dinnertime so we like one big
party that's true yeah I like it's not
everything in the pot flips
simple one pot stew yeah Howie these
spiky things look at this look at my
shoes look at that
this isn't Ted it's a guy like thorns on
them yeah I already got cut on my leg
when I was doing art 10 and then you
were wearing sandals yes oh yeah these
are my sandals I got my sandals babies
thorns dangerous to feel like with these
thorns lying around this should not be a
campsite kind of more undecided that
this should be a great campsite thorns
everywhere we dry here - and we got a
notice saying that we're not supposed to
swim at the lake we came here for the
lake it's called Pyramid Lake huh no I'm
calling the person that decided Pyramid
Lake should be a campsite as a [ __ ] so
we came to Pyramid Lake for a fun
weekend camping and swimming this is
what they had to say about swimming
toxins from algae is in the water and
they don't want us to swim cantering
trips going fantastic
[Music]
Familia hey Isaac
huh sure
Oh fine 50 guys
[Music]
[Music]
it's not so good yeah like we're in the
desert making like meat stuff this is
actually a pretty like outdoorsy meal
na+ do beef stew is a pretty like
country thing to make that were
controlled up Oregon Trail food yeah you
know anymore okay this looks like the
beef stew that's in them what's that
Tarantino film carefully hateful eight
yeah yes beef stew or a little a beef
stew and they made it look so good too
in that movie I don't you start off with
like it being full what Sam all the taxi
yeah yeah so cold you know I need
something warm
well they talked about coffee you like
all it's like the best coffee in the
world
hot coffee right now users thank you
mama
[Music]
it was really hot good
[Music]
[Music]
does it work as a nice pretending using
minecraft minecraft' first biopic and
now Indian Jones so David was talking
about the about a movie and he was like
yeah is that movie a biopic or and no
one calls it a biopic it's a biopic but
now he's swearing that it's called
biopic so there's plenty of reason to
assume that a biopic is pronounced
biopic usually when people learn the
words etymology they quickly revise
their pronunciation sometimes they're
embarrassed by their earlier
pronunciation thus people pronouncing it
biopic its biopic yeah exactly because I
knew I was right in all your faces now I
could sleep great and now I look like a
dumbass you can't though because it's
correct
[Applause]
that's all good biopic in your face
[Music]
[Music]